alright guys I think the most important
and pressing question is now that
cryptocurrency gets all the attention
an AI is no longer the hottest thing of
technology how are you dealing with it
yeah been Hamner of Kaggle had a good
line on this he said something like
great thing about cryptocurrency as
people no longer ask me about whether
there's an AI bubble and yeah it's hard
to compete with the crypto bubble or
phenomenon whatever you want to call it
it's actually yeah good development
right like I mean the history of AI is
like all of these winners and like
having another hype cycle to kind of
balance it out might actually be a good
thing yeah absolutely
let's talk about your paper to start it
off mile so yeah what is it called and
yeah where do you yeah it's called the
malicious use of artificial intelligence
and there's a subtitle like forecasting
prevention and mitigation and it's
attempting to be the most comprehensive
analysis to date of the various ways
which AI could be deliberately misused
so not just things like bias and lack of
fairness and an algorithm that are not
necessarily intentional but deliberately
using it for things like fake news
generation and you know combining AI
with drones to carry out terrorist
terrorist attacks or offensive cyber
security applications and you know the
essential argument that we make is that
that needs to be taken seriously the
fact that AI is a dual use or even Omni
use technology and that similar to other
fields like biotechnology and computer
security we need to think about whether
their norms that account for that so
things like responsible disclosure when
you find out about a new vulnerability
is something that's pervasive in the
computer security community but hasn't
yet been seriously discussed for things
like adversarial examples where you
might want to say hey there's this new
misuse opportunity or way in which you
could fool this like commercial system
that is currently you know running
driverless cars or whatever and so there
there should be some more discussion
about those sorts of issues mmm okay and
so is it going into the technical
details or is it kind of a survey of
where you think things yeah so most of
its a general survey but then there's
like an appendix on different areas like
you know how to deal with the privacy
issues how to deal with you know the
robustness issues and
you know different places to look for
lessons okay and so Tim have you been
focusing on any of the stuff while
you've been here at Oxford or is your
work totally unrelated it's somewhat
related actually I mean I would say that
I've mostly been focusing on what you
might think of as a subset of the
problems that miles is working on where
he's sort of saying look AI isn't gonna
be inherently used for good and in fact
there's lots of intentional ways to use
it for for bad right and one things I've
been thinking about is the sort of
interface between these techniques and
the problems with disinformation and
like whether or not you think these
techniques will be used to make you know
ever more believable fakes in the future
and what that does to the media
ecosystem so I would say it's like a
very particular kind of bad actor use
that miles talking about mm-hm and so
when you're doing this research for both
of these topics are you digging into
actual code like how are you spotting
spotting this in the wild yeah so I mean
my methodology is really kind of focused
on looking at what is the research
that's coming out right now and like
trying to extrapolate what the uses
might be right because I think one of
the really interesting things we're
seeing in the ad space is that it is
becoming more available for people to do
right like you've got these cloud
services you know we've got the tools
are like widely available now and so I
think what's really missing is like the
ability to kind of figure out like how
you do it right like what is the
methodology that you use and the
question is can you see papers that are
coming out and saying hey we could
actually use it for this somewhat
disturbing purpose and then kind of
extrapolating from there to say like
okay well what would it mean for it to
get used more widely mm-hmm
yeah yeah so like reading papers saying
what the hot areas are and and you know
cases in which some sort of potentially
negative or positive application is you
know on the cusp of getting just
efficient enough to be used by a wide
array people or you know the hyper
parameter optimization problem is close
to being solved or whatever sort of
trend that you might see like might be a
sign that certain technologies are going
to be more widely usable not just by
experts but potentially and you know a
huge range of applications for the
purpose of this report that I recently
wrote you know we got a ton of people
together including Tim at a workshop and
we talked about you know technical
trends and you had people and like
cybersecurity and AI and other areas
sort of you know
compare best guesses of what's possible
and then prioritize what the risks are
and what to do about them
so I think you know a lot of I think
often like pulling together different
disciplines is a good way to think about
what what's possible and then one other
thing that I'll point out is that you
don't necessarily have to even look into
the technical literature to find you
know discussion of these sorts of misuse
applications today because it's like a
hot topic already so things like deep
fakes for you know face swapping and
pornography is like a huge media issue
right now that actually happened while
we were writing this report and then we
like added something later about it
because we we talked we characterized
the general issue of you know fake
videos and yeah you know misinformation
and AI as making that more scalable
because you know potentially requires
less expertise and like while we're
writing that this deep fake thing
happens and it's you know democratizing
in some sense the ability to like you
know create fake videos so it's yeah
it's quite a live issue right I think
there's a really interesting question
here particularly when you think about
like prediction about like there's the
realm of what can be done and then
trying to understand like what's likely
to actually happen
Mrak this seems to be the really
challenging thing because there's like
lots of terrible uses for almost every
technology yeah
right but we see certain users more
prominently than others right and I
think that's actually where the the Robo
on this sort of stuff is and actually as
part of this prediction problem yeah and
and yeah so that's why you kind of have
to yeah I mean first of all have some
humility about like you know what what
you can predict like you know if it's a
if it's a fully general-purpose or a
fairly general purpose technology they
can be steered in a bunch of different
directions or applied to a bunch of
different data sets then you know you
should expect it if it's super widely
available a bunch of people are gonna
find new uses for it so that I mean that
I think that's a reason to sort of look
upstream at the papers and see like
where the technical trends are because
then you can say like well you know
maybe this is not yet ready for
primetime for any application or like
this is starting to be like fairly
general purpose yeah I mean a good
question for you models is whether or
not you think that like we'll see like
the virtual uses be the ones that happen
first the versus the physical ones right
so some people have said okay well you
could use AI to really make you know
hacking much easier right we might be
able use it to write create these like
fakes right which were already
but I'm wondering if those threats kind
of evolved in a way that's like
different or maybe even earlier then you
know threats of like you know if people
talk about like Oh what happens if like
someone built a drone that goes out and
yeah that rhythms to go hurt people yeah
it's hard to say I mean I think one you
know you're a stick that I've used is
that you know stuff in the physical
world is often harder and yeah that like
it's both more expensive and less
scalable is you have to buy actual
robots and then there's often Hardware
issues that you run into and like the
general problem of perception and
perception is much harder in the real
world and in like you know static
datasets but you know we're seeing
progress like just a few days ago there
are a bunch of cool videos from sky do
of their autonomous drone for like
tracking people doing sports and flying
around and seems to be pretty good at
navigating and forests and things like
that so you know maybe technologies like
that are sort of a sign that you know
there'll be much more both positive and
negative uses in the real world but but
yeah I think in terms of you know
near-term impact I think you know those
sorts of things that have those
autonomous features still aren't super
easy to use for an end users outside of
like a particular domain so I'm not sure
that like anyone could just easily you
know repurpose it to you know track a
particular person or whatever I think
it's sort of for that domain application
and I don't know how expensive it is but
yeah probably more expensive than like a
twenty dollar drive right I think about
like what is like what's like the first
harm that comes out of the gate yeah in
a big way because I've debated often
like okay so like say there's a horrible
self-driving car like incident that
occurs right like maybe that turns
society off in general to the whole
technology and like there's a big
categorical outlawing of it you like I'm
like okay that that's kind of not so
good right but at the same time I'm kind
of like okay well what if like hacking
becomes a lot more prominent in a way
that's powered by machine learning but
like we know that like I don't know the
response to like huge data disclosures
or huge data compromises it's like
actually quite limited public response
right and that seems not so good either
is basically like people either overrun
overestimate the risk or underestimate
the risk depending on like what happens
first yeah yeah people are starting to
get kind of desensitized to the you know
these mega disclosures and and so maybe
they won't even care if there's some
adaptive malware thing that that you
know that we might be like whoa that's
that's kind of scary but it could be
that you know something truly
catastrophic could happen if you sort of
combine the scalability of AI and
digital technology in general with like
the adaptability of human intelligence
for like finding vulnerabilities if you
put those together you might have like a
really bad you know cyber incident that
will actually like people make people be
aquo this AI thing yeah so that's
something that worries me a lot but it's
sort of like a moving goalpost on the
positive and negative side right like so
you know newsfeed for instance like you
could call that AI to a certain extent
right as it's feeding you information
people get mad at newsfeed they don't
get mad at AI right so like the notion
that the public would generally turn on
something like that seems almost
unrealistic right because you want to
point at one thing right I mean I think
that's it is basically like what the
public thinks about as AI is an AI right
what we're actually talking about is
like this weird amalgam of like popular
culture some research explanations that
make it to the public you know all these
sorts of things and there's so much
about like what is what does the public
actually think AI even is which is
really relevant to the discussion right
because right like the newsfeed
assuredly is AI right it uses machine
learning uses the latest machine
learning to do what it does we don't
really think about it as AI right
whereas like the car is like a I mean I
think a lot of robots kind of fall into
this category where even robots that
don't involve any machine learning are
thought of as AI fry and like actually
impact a discussion about AI despite not
actually being related to it at all and
like absolute sense well then it sort of
becomes a design challenge right it's
like why these self-driving cars are
shaped like little bubbly toys right
there's so much less intimidating when
you see it just like bump into like a
little bollard on the street here
whatever but yeah the robot like the
factory robot for instance like those
are terrifying to people but they've
always been terrifying there's no
difference here but surely there are
positive things that you guys notice you
know you're going around to these
conferences like what what are what
questions are people asking you about AI
what is the public concerned about
positively and negatively hmm so I think
there's two things that are really on
top of minds that I think keep coming up
with in the popular discussion around AI
right now and also among like research
or circles that's right so the first one
is the question
like international competition and like
what it looks like in the space so this
is a question of like it seems like
China's making a lot of moves to really
invest in AI in a big way what does that
mean about like these research fields
right well like the US and Canada and
Europe sort of stay ahead in this game
will they fall behind and what does that
mean if you think that like governments
are gonna see this as like a national
security thing so that's like one issue
I hear a lot about the second one I
think is around the issues of like
interpret ility right which which I
think are really big concern which is
these systems make decisions can we
render some kind of satisfying
explanation for why they do what they do
and I use the word satisfy specifically
there because there's lots of ways of
trying to tell like how they do what
they do but like this question of how
you communicate is a whole nother issue
and those seem to be like two really big
challenges I'm sure miles has any other
things yeah I mean there's a lot going
on the whole like fatty metal community
fairness accountability and transparency
machine learning and and now there's
like fat star so it's like more general
than just machine learning at conference
series and and you know broader
community has been doing a ton of
Awesome work in this on those sorts of
issues but you know in addition to the
transparency thing that Tim mentioned I
would also mention robustness so that's
a huge concern and pretty much you know
if you look at the like offense and
defense and competitions on adversarial
examples like the often stems like we
don't really know how to make neural
Nets robust against deliberate or even
unintentional things that could mess
them up like you know they do really
well according to you know one single
number of like you know human versus AI
performance but then if it's slightly
outside the distribution they might fail
or if you know someone's deliberately
tampering with it so that's a huge
problem for actually applying these
systems in the real world and and I
think you know we'll continue to see
progress on that but we'll also see
setbacks where people say well this this
proposal you had for for defending you
know no that's actually doesn't work and
then there are all sorts of other things
besides just adversarial examples like
you know there was a recent paper called
bad Nets they talked about like
backdoors and neural network so
essentially like someone can put trained
neural network on github or wherever and
then you know it seems to work fine but
then like you know you show it some
special image and then it goes wrong so
yeah there are issues around that in
terms of positive applications one area
that is super exciting and that it's
there's so much work on it that I've had
to like sort of you know take a step
back and like not even try to like tweet
all the interesting stuff I see on it is
a health so there's like pretty much
every day on archive there's a new paper
that's like you know superhuman
performance on you know this you know
dermatology task or this like you know
you know this esophageal cancer task so
there's like a ton of activity in that
space and there's that specific to for
instance like image recognition like CT
scan type so there's a lot of image
recognition I think that's like kind of
the low-hanging fruit yes there's all
this progress in a recognition and like
things like adversarial examples aren't
necessarily a problem in that domain
like you're you're hoping that a patient
isn't like fiddling with their image or
like putting you know a little turtle on
their chest when they're getting scanned
and then it like gives the wrong answer
so so yeah there's tons of applications
there but there's also just more general
machine learning stuff like predicting
you know people relapsing and like
having to come back to the hospital and
like went ones optimal time to like you
know send people home or like given this
huge data set of people's you know
medical history is what's the best
diagnosis so there's a lot other other
applications yeah there's a workshop end
nap there's a workshop at nips appears
back was it two years ago that was
basically like AI in the wild it was the
name of it and I think that's like a
really good way of framing up a lot of
the issues that we're seeing right now
is like we're moving out of the lab in
some sense where it's like okay the old
tasks used to be just like could we
optimize this algorithm it to kind of do
this thing better but like now there's a
bunch of like research trying to figure
out like what do we do when we confront
like the practical problems of deploying
these things like in the world and and
that links a lot of the inner ability
stuff it links a lot of the safety stuff
it links these questions that are
specific to health like I think all
these come out of a fact that like the
technology is really finally becoming
practical and so you have to solve some
of these really practical questions mmm
and so as far as like deploying this
stuff in the wild in the health use case
like who is using it right now where are
we seeing it a lot of its pilot stuff so
like maybe a hospital here yeah Medical
Center there I am not sure of you know
at any super widely deployed ones except
for like apps for very specific things
like you know
looking at skin lesions and stuff but
yeah as I said it's something that's
like so active that like I'm not the
best person to ask because it's just
like I like haven't even you know tried
like you know assess what what's the
hottest thing in this area this is just
like everyday there's like Oh new pilot
on this and but but a lot of it you know
as Tim said is like at this age where it
might get rolled out but it hasn't yet
been rolled out so they're like pilots
on the one hand but then there's also a
lot of stuff that's just training on
offline data and they're like well if we
had implemented this it would have been
good but you know they're issues around
interpretability
and you know fairness and stuff like
that that would you know have to be
resolved before was actually widely
deployed right I mean one of the
interpretive debates that I'm loving
right now is basically so Zakk Lipton
this machine learning researcher did
this great paper called the doctor just
won't accept that right and it's
basically a reference to that that trope
and a lot of the discussions where it's
like well the doctor won't accept that
it's like not Interlake it's not
interpret bull I mean it's not
interpreted well and like he's
challenging I think what is like a
really big question right which is like
will they care in the end like will
interpretability actually matter in the
ends and like are we actually in some
ways is like the field actually like you
know over indexing on that or maybe in
the very least not thinking as nuanced
as it should be about like what kinds of
interpret er actually needed or expected
in the space and I think that's like one
big question is just like you know will
these things become the norm for the
technology or will you know the market
kind of adopted even without those those
things and I think you're worried about
the safety of these technologies ends up
being a question question not just of
like can we develop the methods but can
they be something that's just like
expected that you use when you deploy
the technology because it's possible
that if you just sort of leave it to the
market that will just kind of rush ahead
without actually anything you know how
to build a microphone yeah you're
totally fine using it there's always
things in like you probably see it with
like you know anti-vaxxers mm-hm they're
like the old-school homegrown version
maybe that they don't want to accept it
but the rest of the world seems totally
fine then yeah and I just another point
I think there likely to be differences
cross nationally not just like
international in terms of who's gonna be
willing to accept what is you know
countries in the European Union might be
like much more and the European at the
EU level there might be a lot more
regulation
these sorts of things you know there's
this whole discussion around right to an
explanation and the general data
protection regime in China there's like
much letter I haven't seen as much
concern about interpretability though
there are some like good papers coming
out of China but in terms of like
governance I haven't gotten the sense
that they're gonna like hold back the
deployment of these technologies for
those reasons and then in the US maybe
it's like somewhere between the two I
mean it's a real battle of like I was
reflecting on this because I saw a
debate on interpret ility recently where
some researchers were like no one cares
let's just roll ahead with this stuff so
just a pause reaction let's define that
just in case someone is listening who's
not like an AI yeah sure so I think the
most colloquial way of talking about it
is interpret E is kind of the study of
the methods that let you understand like
why a machine learning system makes the
decisions that it does right an other
way is like kind of like an audit to
understand how you got this out that's
right exactly right and there's two sets
of problems there one of them is can you
actually extract like a meaningful
explanation to like
technicians and then there's the other
question of just like from a user point
of view like you know just like a doctor
or someone who's not like a domain
expert on machine learning yeah being
able to understand what's going on right
okay right and the debate I think
focused on just like does it matter
right because I think there's some
machine learning folks who are like look
if it works it works you know and and
that's ultimately gonna be the way we're
gonna move ahead on this stuff and some
people say no we actually want to have
some level explanation and I actually
kind of got the feeling that in some
ways this is sort of like machine
learning fighting with the rest of the
computer science field right cuz like
when you're learning CS it's very much
about like can you figure out like every
step of the process right and like you
know where as machine learning has
always been like empirical in some sense
right like in the sense that like we
just let where the data tells us train
the system right and like those are
actually two ways of like knowing the
world that are actually debating on this
question of interpretation it's it's
sort of like statistical significance
and bio where is like I don't know it
works five out of five hundred times
like therefore it works fine it's not a
computer yeah and so and what are people
pushing for like for instance you know
we're in the UK now in the u.s. how are
the conversations different hmm so I
mean I think there is certainly very
different regimes around like what is
sort of expected from explanation right
because I think and this actually spent
stems from some really interesting
things about like how the US thinks
about privacy and how the Europe thinks
about privacy but I would say in general
I think the u.s. moves on a very
case-by-case basis so the regulatory
mode is basically to say look in medical
that seems to be a situation where like
there's like particularly high risks and
like we want to create a bunch of
regimes that are specific to medical
whereas in Europe I think there's like
broader regimes where the frame is
for example automated decision making
okay right and and the gt-r applies to
automated decision making systems which
is very broad and the actual
interpretation will narrow that
considerably but you start from a big
kind of category and you narrow down
versus an approach I think which is
taking much more like just starting from
the domain that we think is significant
so it's it's more patchwork II I guess
in that sense yeah you would agree so I
I'm curious about your PhD what are you
working on and you're almost done so
yeah so I'm studying science policy and
the work amend dissertation is on like
what sorts of methods are useful for AI
policy and you know the the problem that
I posed is that there's so much
uncertainty like there there's
uncertainty as we were just talking
about about what where AI will be
applied but then there's also you know
deep expert disagreement about how long
it will take to get the certain
capabilities like a human level AI or
even if that's like well-defined and
that let alone what happens after so
I've been taking more of a like scenario
planning approach like let's think about
multiple possible scenarios and I've
done some you know workshops and I'm
trying to understand you know is that a
useful tool and also can we do like your
models that sort of Express this
uncertainty and in some sort of formal
way yeah there's a lot of like history
you've looked into there too yeah yeah
yeah so I mean I I think that one way to
yeah so I mean people have been talking
about a ai ai ethics and AI governance
for a long time but there hasn't been
much dialogue between you know this
world and then the other worlds of like
you know science policy and public
policy and and you know one way to think
about is that AI is sort of less mature
in terms of its you know methodological
rigor la
you know the best we've sort of come up
with is like let's do a survey of some
experts where as an you know you look at
something like climate change
you know they not they not only like you
know do surveys of experts but also like
synthesize that expertise into like an
IPCC report that's supposed to be a
super authoritative and has you know
error bars for everything and like
levels of confidence in different
statements they have this whole process
they have models of different possible
futures given different assumptions
everything sort of much better spelled
out in terms of you know the links
between assumptions and policies and
scenarios so I think yeah I'm trying to
take one small step in that direction of
like more rigor and more sort of clarity
of you know what what are the actual
disagreements mm-hmm are you guys um are
you familiar with the history of policy
because I was driving over here with my
girlfriend and she asked me like has
this like policy ecosystem around AI
always existed around CS like for
instance you know when rioting started
where people at questioning the policy
of like what does this mean is this like
a new phenomenon given that you know you
can establish for a lack of a better
word like like a personal brand and like
disseminated it out to the world or you
know have their you know kind of always
been policy advisors and isn't in as
many number as you guys like working
directly with governments and companies
and stuff like that yeah I don't know
about writing but definitely early
actually yeah but but certainly things
like nuclear weapons and nuclear energy
and you know solar energy and coal and
you know cars there were people debating
the social implications and there were
calls for regulation and there were
conflicts between you know the incumbent
interests and the start-up innovators so
I think you know those sorts of issues
are not new I think what's more new is
as you said there's like an ability to
spread you know views more quickly and
to have sort of global conversations
about these things mm-hmm yeah I mean I
think it's just sort of linked to the
notion of like having specialists
develop policy at all like I think
that's like kind of the history of this
right which is like when do certain
situations become considered so complex
as to require someone to be able to like
be like okay I can
become an expert on it and be like the
person who's consulted on this topic and
I think a little bit about like what is
like this supply of policy and then also
like what is the demand for policy right
so like in the nuclear war case right
like governments have a lot of interest
in trying to figure out how we avoid
like chucking nuclear bombs at one
another I think so like suddenly there's
a really strong demand there's also like
funding there all these like there's all
these reasons for policy people to kind
of enter the space and I think AI is
sort of interesting in that it kind of
like floats in this median zone right
now right where it's sort of like you
see this happen a lot where people like
AI it seems like a really big deal but
then they get into the room and they're
like so what are we doing here exactly
like what what what is what is policy
and AI and I think that is part of the
challenge right now is trying to figure
out like what are the things that are
really valuable to kind of work on if
you think this is going to continue to
become like a big issue because right
now the technology is nascent in a way
that we can argue about the relative
impact of it at all right and then and
then we can argue about like does it
make sense to actually have kind of like
policy people like you guys I mean
obviously there are a lot of machine
learning papers coming out all the time
but you're very much at the forefront
like oftentimes I feel like you're sort
of like ahead of the curve a little bit
like anticipating the needs and demands
of a company or of a government and so
like planning head for the future like
are you just like waiting for data to
come are you like getting within
companies to like see what they're
working on you like learning about the
hardware how are you spending your time
to figure out what's coming next
yeah I mean a lot of is just talking to
people talking to people working on
hardware and you know in in industry and
academia and like what they're working
on and and sort of you know I mean I
find it personally helpful to have some
some sort of predictions or you know you
know explicit model of you know of the
future and you know written some like
blog post about this like my forecast
for like short-term so like in 2017 I
made a bunch of predictions I found that
to be a super useful exercise because
then I could say okay what was I wrong
about and was there like were there
systematic ways in which I can sort of
be better about anticipating the future
next time yeah and I think we had asked
interesting question about like what is
what is policy expertise because it's
like different in different situations
yeah so imagine like the the nuclear
case and then you actually knew the
nuclear case is pretty interests
because early on the experts from a
policy perspective also were like the
physicists right and like you can
imagine that existing actually in a
field we're in a technical field which
is society is like okay what do we do
with this technology and the response is
well the scientists working on it will
tell you about right but is sort of
interesting in that like there has been
kind of the development of a community
of people that I feel is fairly nason
which i think suggests to me that like
at least with two options right like one
of them is that like the field could be
like the technical field could be doing
more policy stuff but isn't right now or
though it's an arbitrage maybe yeah I
mean that's maybe one way of thinking
about I mean but there's also like this
other question of just like what are
other things that might help to inform
the technical research okay right like I
think a lot of my policy work really is
like translation work right we like talk
to policy people who are like well I
understand like liability mm-hmm and I'm
like well you know this is it's mixed up
because of AI because of ABC reasons
right and so like it's bringing like the
technical research to an existing policy
discussion there's also the reverse that
happens right which is basically like
researchers being like what is this
fairness thing right and you're like
well it turns out that you can't just
create a score for fairness like there's
these really interesting things that
people have written about you know like
how do you think about translating that
into the machine learning space as well
which is kind of where you can read like
fat ml doing and so I think that that
translation role is like it's by no
means certain but in the AI space seems
to have been like a useful role for
people to play again thinking about like
what is the plot like policy supply and
policy demands yeah absolutely
yeah I think collaboration is
super-important between people
interested in the societal questions and
the technical questions and and you know
it's rare not just an AI but in other
cases to like have the answer like you
know readily available so with like the
IC IPCC for climate change like they
have to go back to the lab sometimes and
do new studies because they're trying to
answer policy relevant questions so I
think AI might be the sort of case where
there's sort of this feedback loop
between people saying okay here are the
questions that AI people need to answer
like here the assumptions we need to
flesh out like in terms of you know how
quickly will we have this capability and
and so forth that that you can't just
find that existing on archive like the
answers aren't just lying out there
ready to be taken by policy people I
think there needs to be this sort of
collaboration yeah I'd love to actually
look into the history of how
evolved in the climate science right cuz
you can imagine situation we're like you
hear this from some machine learning
people sometimes or just like I just
programmed the algorithms man like other
people have to deal with like I don't
know the implications of that right and
like yeah presumably you could actually
have that in the climate space as well
where research could be like all I do is
really measure the climate man like you
decide if you want to change the
missions like gross not my deal but
clearly like that field has Macon taken
the choice to basically say like in
addition to our research work we have
this other obligation right which is to
engage in this policy debate right right
and and I think that is really
interesting is like what does the field
actually think it's responsibilities
even are and then like how do other kind
of like skills or talents arrange
themselves around that so then the
question ends up being like Tim you were
at Google before mm-hmm Neri we're at
the future of humanity Institute and how
do you guys deal with policy both within
an institute and within a company like
what are the differences and how do
those relationships work yeah definitely
so I've got kind of a weird set of
experience I think just because like I
was yet doing public policy for Google
so that was like very much on the
company side of things and then now I'm
doing a little bit of work with Harvard
and MIT on this ethics and governance of
AI and I should have been doing work
with the Oxford internet Institute as
well and it is interesting like the
degree to which you know you actually
find that like people in both spaces are
often concerned about the same things
but the the constraints that they
operate under are very difference right
so you know both sides I think like I
talked to a bunch of researchers within
Google who are like very concerned about
fairness I talked to researchers outside
of Google who are in civil society right
who are very concerned about fairness
have you found the same to be true yeah
yeah so I think there are people worried
about the same issues and a bunch of
different domains but they they differ
in terms of you know how much time
they're able to focus on them and what
sorts of concrete issues they have to
answer so like if you're an industry you
have to sort of think about the actual
applications that you're rolling out or
like you know fairness as it relates to
this product you know assuming that
you're working on the application side
they're also researchers who are
interested in the more fundamental
question but in terms of you know
different institutions and you know if
you're in government you might have a
broader mandate but you don't have the
time to like drill down into every
single issue you need to sort of rely to
some extent on experts outside the
government who are you know writing
reports and things like that and then if
you're in academia you know you might be
able to take a super broad perspective
you're not necessarily as close to the
you know cutting-edge research and you
have to sort of rely on having
connections with industry so for example
at the future humanity Institute we have
a lot of relationships with
organizations like deep mind and open AI
and others but you know that we don't
have like a ton of you know GPUs or
UVU's here like running the latest
experiments outside of you know some
specific domains like safety so yeah I
think you know having those different
sectors and dialogue is super important
in order to like have have a you know
synthesis of you know the what are the
actual practical problems were pressing
what are the governance issues we need
to address across this whole thing and
then like you know what are the issues
we need people to drill down on and
focus and like do sort of you know free
rein you know wide-ranging exploration
of that are like further down the road
and so what does the population look
like here of researchers I'm curious in
the sense of like who's around like
influencing your ideas like what are
their backgrounds what are they working
on yeah so it's at the future of
humanity Institute it's a mix of people
so there's some philosophers an ethicist
there's some political scientists
there's some mathematicians and you know
it's it's basically a mix of people who
are interested in both AI or not
everyone's working on AI but AI and
biotechnology are too like technical
areas of focus but also more general
issues related to the future of humanity
as the name suggests so it's pretty
interdisciplinary like people aren't
necessarily working just in the domain
that they're coming from like the
mathematicians aren't necessarily you
know trying to you know prove math
theorems but rather just like bringing
that mindset of you know rigor to their
work and trying to like you know break
down the concepts that we're thinking
about yeah I'm curious about this too
because I've never really understood
this about FHI is is sort of the
argument that like thinking about
existential risk there's like practices
that apply across all these different
domains or do they kind of operate as
sort of like separate research we should
pause there to like is the existential
risk at the crux of the FHI being
founded yeah so it's it's a major
motivation for a lot of our work so
book superintelligence by our founder
you know talked a lot about existential
risks associated with AI but but it's
not the entirety of our focus so we also
are interested in you know long-term
issues that aren't necessarily
existential and also making sure that we
get to the upsides so I think I'm altima
pretty optimistic about the the positive
applications of AI so I think you know
we do a range of issues but yeah there
but like to Tim's question there are a
lot of people who come at this from sort
of you know like very conceptual and and
like you know utility maximizing you
know philosophical perspective of like
whoa if we were to like lose all the
possible value in the future B's
humanity to stop that would be you know
one of the worst things that could
possibly happen and so like reducing the
probability of existential risk is super
important even if AI is you know decades
or centuries away and even if we can
only you know decrease the probability
you know of that happening by like 0.1%
or whatever in expectation that's like a
huge amount of value that you're
protecting so before we wrap things up
I'm curious about your broad thoughts
like what should we be concerned about
in the short term around AI and in the
long term and then how did the two mix
together
yeah definitely I mean so I think this
is one of the really interesting things
is that at least within the community of
policy people and the kind of
researchers right that there has been
this kind of beef yeah well I mean maybe
beef is a little dramatic but a small
beef you know between like what we might
call like yeah the long term like you're
talking about which is like people were
concerned about AGI an existential risk
and all these sorts of things and then
sort of the the short term people saying
like well why do we focus on that when
there's all these problems of how these
systems are being implemented right now
and and yeah I mean I think that is one
of the kind of enduring sort of features
of the landscape right now but I think
it's interesting question as to whether
or not that will be you know the case
forever I I don't know like I know miles
you've had some thoughts on yeah yes I
think there are common sort of topical
issues over different time frame so like
both in the nearer and the long term we
would want to worry about systems being
fair and accountable and transparent and
maybe the methods will be the same or
maybe they'll be different over those
different time horizons and I think
they're also going to be issues around
security over different time horizons so
so yeah I think that you know there's
probably
more common cause between you know the
people working on the immediate issues
and the long-term issues then then is
often perceived but in some people who
see it as like a big trade-off between
like who's gonna get funding or like you
know this is getting too much attention
in the media but I think actually you
know the the goal of most of the people
working in this area is to like maximize
the benefits of AI and minimize the
risks and it might turn out that some of
the same governance approaches are
applicable like it might turn out that
setting that actually solving some of
these near-term issues will set a
positive precedent for solving the
longer ones and start building up a
community of practice and links with
policymakers and expertise in government
so so yeah I think there's a lot of
opportunity for fusion yeah what makes
the models I mean you're in kind of like
the this kind of safety community and
like do you hear people talking about
like I mean I use the phrase fat AGI
which i think is just not fascinating as
a term just because it marries together
these two concepts so well yeah but I
don't know if that's is that being
talked about at all yeah so I think
there yeah there's common cause in the
sense that you could sort of so I mean
what take a step back so one term that
people often throw around in the like AI
safety world particularly looking at
long term AI safety is value alignment
so how do you actually learn the values
of humans and not you know go crazy and
do I mean you know to put it yeah but
but I think you know you could frame a
lot of current issues as value alignment
problems so things around bias and
fairness so I think ultimately you know
that there's a question of how do you
extract human preferences and how do you
deal with the fact that humans might not
have consistent preferences and some of
them are biased so I think you know
ultimately those are issues that we'll
have to deal with in the near term and
like might take a different form in the
future of AI systems are operating you
know with a much larger action space
they're not just like classifying data
but they're you know taking you know
very long-term decisions and thinking
you know abstractly
but yeah I think you know ultimately the
the goal is the same it's still like get
you know the right behavior out of these
systems mm-hmm and that was very
interesting cuz the example that you
just gave was saying you know a lot of
the fairness problems
we're dealing with right yeah we
actually value alignment problems yes
like the problem there is basically the
system doesn't behave in a way that's
like consistent with human values yeah
so that's the fairness case and then
yeah so like you know that's the F in
the fat ya acronym I mean to take
accountability and transparency I think
there's also common cause so you know
one of the issues I've been toying with
recently is that that transparency might
be a way of avoiding certain you know
international conflicts or it might be
part of the toolbox so historically in
arms control agreements like around
nuclear weapons and chemical weapons
there been things like on-site
inspections and you know satellite
monitoring and you know all these tools
that are sort of bespoke for the purpose
of the domain but the general concept is
we would be better off cooperating and
we will verify that that behavior is
actually happening and so that you know
if if we detect defection by the Soviet
Union or the Soviet Union detects
defection from us then they can respond
appropriately but you know we can build
you know trust but verify and Reagan's
terminology and I think if if you
actually had the full development of the
phat methods and you had accountability
and transparency for even general AI
systems or super intelligence systems I
think that would open up the door for a
lot more collaboration if you could sort
of credibly commit to saying okay you
know we're developing this general AI
system but you know these are its goals
or this is how it learns its goals and
you know we're sort of you know putting
these hard constraints on the system
such that it's not gonna attack your
country or whatever yeah I think it's I
mean one of the things that's so
intriguing about it though is like the
reason why I like fat AGI for me is like
huh it's like kind of like kind of a
crazy idea is because I know typically
in like the literature around AGI it's
very much like the idea that it would be
accountable and that it could be
transparent is usually considered
impossible right because like yeah yeah
so complex and so powerful that it would
like that nothing could buy us yeah I
mean we're making the move you're making
is to say like actually we might we
might be able to do it yeah well there
differences of opinion on like how sort
of interactive the development of you
know an AGI would be and
and you know the extent to which humans
will be in the loop you know over the
long under the end right and so I mean
Paul Christiano at open AI for example
has a lot of really good blog posts and
you know some of these ideas are in the
paper concrete problems in AI safety
about you know about the idea that you
know corrigible what he calls core
ability and what others have called core
ability might actually be like a stable
basin of Attraction in the sense that if
a system you know is designed in such a
way that it's able to like take critical
feedback and its able to say okay yeah
what I was doing was wrong that might
sort of like stabilize in a way that
it's like continuously asking for human
feedback so it's possible that
accountability is you know an easier
problem even for very powerful systems
than we realize like you know there are
powerful you know maybe Trump aside
there are powerful people in the world
who actually seek our critical feedback
and like are aware and like more topical
yeah want to hear diverse inputs and
like we want to make sure that they're
doing the right thing right right but
this is actually really interesting
because it's like it's both short term
and long term again right just like if
we could get the research community to
have certain norms around ensuring that
like we are seeking to build corrigible
systems yes right yeah that might set
the president that the idea that
eventually arrives yeah will be one
which is actually consistent with phat
yeah right versus like not right we
actually have control over the design of
the yeah thing I've always had such
trouble understanding like the people
who thought there are these AI engineers
that we're trying to take over the world
with their AG is like no they're gonna
die too like all the incentives the
incentives are aligned just like imagine
this apocalyptic scenario but do you
guys have you have strong opinions on
people working in public first working
in private I know there's like somewhat
of a debate around development mmm-hmm
yes you mean like working in the US
government no no sorry uh Juvenal in Yin
on like trying to build an AGI okay I
think some amount of your data or
training data yeah publicly vers private
yeah so that's a super interesting
question and I think you know we sort of
broached the the topic and in this
report on the malicious uses of AI
because I think there might be specific
domains in which you know maybe it's not
maybe in a world in which you know isn't
necessarily the world we're in today but
maybe in a world in which you know there
are millions of driverless cars and
they're all using the same like
convolutional neural net that is like
vulnerable to this like new adversarial
example that you just came up with you
might want to like give those companies
a heads up before you just like posted
on archive and then someone can like
cause tens of thousands of car crashes
or whatever so I think you know we might
want to think about norms around
openness and those specific domains
where you know the the idea is until
like never publish but it's to like have
some sort of process but yeah as far as
general AI and and research right now
the community is pretty open and I think
it's sort of both in the you know broad
interest and in the individual interests
of companies to be fairly open means
they want to recruit researchers and
researchers want to publish so I think
yeah there's a pretty strong norm around
openness but if we were in a world where
there was like more widely perceived you
know great power competition between
countries or where the safety issues
were a lot more salient or there were
some like catastrophic misuses of AI in
the cyber arena then I think people
might think twice and it might be
appropriate to think twice if if you
know your concern is that you know it
that the first people to you know press
the button if they're not you know
conscious of all the safety issues could
cause a huge problem yeah I'm very Pro
open publishing like I think like it
should be the default and and it's like
I'm I'm still disputing situations where
I'm like you shouldn't publish on this
stuff just because like I think it is
actually to the benefit of everybody to
know what the current state of the field
is because it allows us to make like a
realistic assessments regardless of
whether or not you believe in AGI you
believe in super intelligence like you
know like it's useful just to know like
what can be done because even if you're
thinking about the more prosaic like bad
actor uses right like it's useful to
know like what are the risks and we
can't do that an environment where like
lots of people are kind of holding back
and so so it's important to know the
state of the field at any given time so
we can actually make realistic public
policy otherwise we're really operating
in the dark yeah that's a great point
okay so so my last year you wrote about
predictions for 2017 or 2018 yeah okay I
made the predictions early 2017 and then
I reviewed them like a month ago okay
this year 2018 you can you get a whole
year has not prepared you can have a
three year get a three year time frame
then
even more three more sure yeah I think
there will be superhuman Starcraft and
dota2 probably in that time horizon I in
I think early 2017 that would be the end
of that I gave like 50% chance by the
end of 2018
so this gives me more runway like seven
seventy percent confident that you know
that you know they'll be superhuman
Stark I'm actually less familiar with
dota2 so well I'll say just Starcraft
alright okay Tim I think meta learning
will improve significantly so this is
basically treating machine learning
designing machine learning architectures
as if they were their own machine
learning problem mhm it's something that
basically is done by like machine
learning specialists right now and the
question is how far will machine
learning researchers go and replacing
themselves essentially and and I think
that will get really good in ways that
we don't expect and your insight into
why that will happen is what there's
some of the results that we're seeing
from the research right now just like it
just seems like these networks are able
to kind of tune their parameters in a
way that at least I would have not
expected and so it's it's cool seeing
that that adapts in advance these are
all positive things all right guys well
thanks for your time giving us
you